well remembering that I said that device
motion is a strict superset of device
orientation anything you can do with
device orientation you could do with
device motion however it's going to be
easier to implement things like a
compass or a joystick using device
orientation rather than device motion
however if you want to implement shake
to send feedback you really need the
acceleration sensing that device motion
offers and for a generic game controller
rather than just a joystick you might
find device motion as interesting for
example the role it game that we
demonstrated at i/o use the acceleration
rates from device motion and that way
you could tell what speed the device was
moving and in what direction so it made
it really easy to throw a ball with
pretty good precision one major
difference between these two ap is is
how often they're fired device
orientation is only fired when the
device orientation changes for device
motion it's fired whenever the
acceleration changes on the device which
includes lateral movement so at fire is
pretty often